tells the story of a song
i was in madrid one night in 2002 with
my teacher and friend joaquín sabina
when he told me he had something to
give me he told me jorge i
have some verses with which you have
to write a song note by note
search and on the table the only one I
found was a circular coaster in
which I did not write down the verses that the teacher meditates on, there
were four verses and they said like this
I am a Jewish humor who lives with the
Christians I do not know which god is mine or
what are my  brothers, those verses
really impacted me a lot about the
boy, the botín verses are yours,
my son did not tell me that they were by another
composer called chicho sánchez
ferlosio, less well-known joaquín, but very
great, they also entered into something
that I wanted to say for a long time, the
verses that I did not  he knew very well how I
was getting up to
go home to write when here I am
wait wait he gives me the next
challenge he tells me write the stanzas
p  For that song in tenths
now I'm at that point in my life I
still didn't have a very clear idea
what the tenths were but I'm too
embarrassed to tell the teacher that I didn't
know so I put on my best
understanding face and went to myself  house to look to
see what the tenth was about
there I learned that the tenth is a type of
stanza that exists only in Spanish
that has ten verses very complex very
complex
perhaps the most complex of the one we have
in our language that also has a
date of  specific birth that is very
rare to find in a verse the tenth
was invented in spain in 1591 by a
man named vicente espinel
musician and poet from malaga who
also notice what a coincidence it was
the same one who put the sixth string
what  then it would be the guitar,
the snare of Spain is here, the
tenth with its ten verses crosses to
America just like the
Spanish guitar, but unlike the
Spanish guitar, the Spanish guitar
continues  still alive today on both
sides of the atlantic
but la décima in the place where it was
born in spain it disappeared it became
extinct a couple of centuries ago it is not practiced
at a popular level but nevertheless in
latin america from mexico to chile
all our countries maintain  some
kind of décima in its popular tradition
everywhere they gave it a
different name of making a different music it
has many names more than twenty in
total on the continent but they call it for
example son jarocho méxico so much de
Mejorana in panama
valerón in venezuela found in uruguay
in Argentina repentismo in Cuba in Peru,
for example, they call it the Peruvian tenth
because the tenth is so integrated into our
traditions that if you
ask them all of them are completely
convinced that they were the ones who
invented the tenth in each country and it
also has something very  surprising and it
is that despite the fact that it was
developed separately in each one of the
countries it maintains  today more
than 400 years after the exact same structure was created to
say
rhyme of syllables and various the same
structure that vicente espinel put
in the Spanish baroque
this structure is like this it must contribute a
little above and then they can go
also to the internet and look you can
go to different eight syllables
each the first rhymes with the fourth with the
fifth the second with the third the
sixth with the seventh and with the tenth and
the eighth with the ninth it
is a bit complicated the truth  I
imagined they have tried to write like this during the
week but it is not as complicated as it
seems and it is also incredible that it has
survived with that same structure for more
than four centuries
it is not that complicated because it has an
impressive musicality the tenth
has a type of municipality that is
very  technically difficult to describe
I prefer this is
listening so what I'm going to do
I'm going to recite a tenth for example
one of the ones I heard  ribí for this
song for that I am going to ask you to
concentrate only on the music of the riva
and those who have headphones
there are some that I see who are with the
transmission of the translation that they
take them away for a moment getxo jazz a
sophisticated  and it's called mini work for
you you can seize the office with
infrastructure and it's all about
choreography they have obeyed a
choreography of sound look at it that way it says there is
no death that doesn't hurt me there is no
winning side there is nothing but pain
and  another life that war flies is a
very bad school no matter what costume
you wear forgive me that I did not enlist under
any flag is worth more than any
chimera than a sad piece of cloth that
is once they are executed
[Applause]
I would also applaud him Vicente Espinel
because 426 years the same and writing
three like these just showed you the
second because the first was just
learning and the truth is that it has
some metric errors so I don't know
I went to show as an example that is why it
was fine more or less now that they were
talking about the content of these networks
and I had just returned from giving a
concert in Israel and I was very
moved by a problem that touches me
very closely, which is the
Israeli-Palestinian conflict explained to them
my father's family is Jewish my mother is a
non-practicing Christian
I grew up in a house with a where the
two traditions lived more
or less harmoniously
it was not uncommon to see my Jewish grandfather
dressed in  Santa Claus, for example, a
non-Jewish hole in the synagogue, this one with his pipe
at the family party, as if making
the same face that I understood I was making
when Sabina told me that they had the
verses in tenths for this one for whom
they believed they grew up around  a if it is
particularly painful to see the
difficulty that two parties in
conflict have to put 1 momentarily
the place of the other then about that to
write already had the letter they had the
form that the tenth the c  content but
all this and writing the music I
also put it in context a long time ago I went
to live from Uruguay where I'm from to
Spain and I was very
nostalgic, the truth is that many of
you are away from home and I wanted
communication  it was very Uruguayan but just
like the most Uruguayan genre to say the
milonga
now of course I have been studying the
history of the décima and after
seeing that everyone claims the décima
as their own everyone believes elements
I said I wondered what it means  that
the milonga is Uruguayan look at
the mine it has a rhythmic pattern
that we musicians say 33 21
23 23 points it
has a characteristic accent so so
so so so so so so
but this characteristic rich pattern
comes from Africa already in the ninth century we
find the  brothels of persia in the
13th in spain from where five centuries
later he crossed america with
african slaves while the balkans came together
with a great gypsy scale
original klezmer part that the
ukrainian jewish immigrants take to brooklyn
new york they sing it in their party room
no one goes and the box goes to no one and
laja they go to their neighbor an
argentinian boy of italian origin named
astor piazzolla listens to it incorporates it
and  transforms the tango of the second
half of the 20th century with his with 23 points
3.2 points will be will sing for so so
so so Tartar also played on his
bandoneon a
nineteenth century German instrument created for
churches that could not afford to
buy an organ and that  Incredibly, it
ends in the Río de la Plata. It constitutes
the very essence of tango and the milonga,
as well as another equally
important instrument that abandons the Spanish guitar
[Applause]
to which, by a certain Vicente Espinel, the
16th century added the sixth string that
fixes the  amount of saying that what has been
learned in these 15 years since
the song was born to travel the world
with these four verses written in a
p  osavasos from a bar in Madrid
the tenths the milonga the songs the
people the closer we get to them the more
complex their identity is, the more
nuanced and detailed
I understood that identity is
infinitely dense with an
infinite series of real numbers even if it doesn't
come very close  and extend it never ends
allow me before I sing the
song and say goodbye to this one that after
one last anecdote not long ago
we were in mexico after a
concert and as the promoters of the
concert they know me and they know that I'm a bit
of a freak  tenth and that everywhere
I go he asked about the tenth I
insist that in order to listen to tenths they
organized a concert in
G of son jarocho in his house remember son
jarocho is one of the types of form
that uses the tenth in his stanzas
when  the wonderful musicians
finished playing that which for me is
wonderful the son jarocho finished
playing that that's how they were I'm going to greet him
very excited  and very plain to
thank the musicians for the gift and a
very young boy tells me that he also tells me
that the best of intentions
is that we, sir, are very
proud to keep alive the purest root
of our Mexican identity,
I don't  It turned out to be a lot to say to him, he's not
there, I stayed there looking at him and he gave him
a hug and I left, but
because he was right, he also actually told us
the tenth of his network, but at the
same time, just like inside the
milonga and inside the tenth they are  the
roots much more people from other
places as he told me about league later how
he got to the hotel I kept thinking about
things they are only pure if they do not look at them from
afar it is very important to know our
roots to know where we come from to know
our history but at the same time
as important as knowing where we are from
is understanding that deep down we are all
from nowhere at all and from everywhere
a little many there is the Jewish Moorish milonga
[Music]
for each mur  or lamented in jerusalem the
golden one and a thousand lives wasted for each
commandment
[Music]
I am dust of your wind and although I
sandro of your wound and each
dear stone keeps my deepest love there
is not a stone in the world that is worth
what a life
I am a Jewish morro who lives with the
Christians I don't know which god is mine or
which are my brothers
I don't know which god is mine and which are
my brothers there is no death that does not
hurt me there is no winning side there is
nothing else  what pain and another life that
the war blows up is a very bad school no
matter what costume you wear forgive
me that I did not enlist under any flag
any first is worth more than a sad piece of cloth
I am a Jewish Moor who lives with the
Christians I don't know  that god is mine or
who are my brothers I don't know which god
is the least and which are my brothers
[Music]
and I gave no one permission to kill in my
name
a man is nothing more than a man and if
there is a god he wanted it that way  the same ground you
stepped on  Guirá also opens the way
for me to forget there is no doctrine that does not go and
there is not a people that does not believe in
the chosen people
I am a Moorish Jew who lives with the
Christians I do not know which God is mine
and which are my brothers  and I don't know which
God is the child and which are my
brothers and I am a Jewish Moor who lives
with two Christian women
[Applause]